[Music]
researchers have discovered 97 new areas
of the brain that were previously
completely unknown 97 isn't that crazy
look at that this is a true news story
yeah now these new regions control
different functions thoughts and
behaviors in all of us I thought we'd
take a look at just a few of them for
example this new region of the brain
knows all the lyrics to Billy Joel's we
didn't start this this regions thought
your co-workers would be impressed if
you came back from your island vacation
with cornrows yeah this region is the
one that whispers go ahead just take it
yeah this region prevents you from
ordering sushi at a bowling alley that's
important check this out this is the
region that when you feel social anxiety
at a party makes you bust out a Borat
impression this region right here
decides what to do when you spot a rare
Pokemon in your grandma's open casket
[Applause]
this region right here can almost but
not quite remember what Lance Bass looks
like this region right here finds tall
redheaded guys attractive
very tiny region yeah why is that such a
small region no no the brain anyway and
finally the largest part of the brain
the region that tells you there's better
porn just keep looking
you
you